falconry is the oldest LAN sport known
to man
before you had any gun you use the bird
[Music]
people get into it for different reasons
some people love to hunt I love the fact
that it's an animal then I get to bond
with this beautiful thing my name is
Rodney stocks everyone almost need the
bird man
I grew up Southeast Washington DC I was
selling drugs for maybe 15 years before
I got caught and I ended up going to
jail for a short period of time which
really was the best thing that ever
could have happened to me at that time
buddy the mindset that I had before the
Raptors actually came in was I didn't
care about people didn't care about your
life didn't care about my own life
actually eventually you wake up and when
you realize that you're practicing
insanity you're doing the same thing
over and over the exact same way and
you're looking for a different result I
first started working with birds when I
first started working with earth
conservation course was Raptors I needed
a job I needed some sort of paste to
show because I got in an apartment you
don't get WT selling drugs it wasn't an
overnight thing not by a long shot
however as you kept going and he started
realizing the more joy that you had was
when you were in a middle of the woods
and the birds were flying XP but
everything else was
destruction and death and negativity
the first purge that I have a flu that
came back to me was a Harris Hawk her
name was Harry I let the bird go and she
flew a good 40 50 yards away from you
and I put my arm out and maybe seven
seconds later
[Music]
the tears was just running and I was so
happy it was the greatest feeling in the
world I had no idea what it was I was
even looking for when I ended up finding
it and from that day on I can take that
bird and go anywhere we can been a crowd
of 10,000 people and as soon as that
Birds see me here she comes
that was the highest highs you could
ever have the that was my fix that
animal didn't care if I was black-white
rich-poor dirty clean all that animal
cared about was did I care about it that
I loved it
yes Edie that's all that matters
whatever you want since you can be
making money you can be doing what what
I'm not gonna do with it you can have
ten million dollars I got a bird you
want to trade me your money so I had
this relationship that I had with my
bird
I'll watch your money life outside of
being here is just trying to make people
happy I go to schools hospitals birthday
parties just community outreach my thing
is that encourage educate and excite you
guys know what she loves
I run a program called lookup where we
go out and you just look up I didn't
know we had all of this because we never
look
[Music]
if I love someone I don't let him go
just because they're gone I got this
bird named after my mother I throw this
bird up my mother's Whitney walking
flying over me watching me like she
would have normally been doing who can
ask for anything more than that
you
[Music]